the jurogan experience well you live in
hawaii which is a really interesting
place right because there's a lot of
non-native
animals that have been introduced to
hawaii like yeah pigs and a lot of weird
birds and a lot of
a lot of weird rodents and plants and
all kinds of shut up we got a um
the weird thing that we think is a
wallaby i think you guys are wallabies
now yeah how crazy is that right
from australia you don't see them but
they're little kangaroos right there's a
little camera yeah
we have wallabies on our i was like how
the [ __ ] did you get here
but they're not like crazy they're like
you're out you see it like they're very
mysterious like they pop up here and
there when people are hiking in the
mountains
yeah but it's like a wallaby bro like
how the hell i don't know how they
traveled there maybe they
i mean australia's isn't surfing and
whatever it is jumping
i'm out of here i think probably
somebody had it as a pet
if i had a guess i'm sure i'm trying to
you hear of a bunch of illegal pets that
people have in hawaii it's
just mind-blowing you know i'm like what
the [ __ ] like i heard stories of people
having like um
gorillas and [ __ ] i'm like what i don't
know
yeah like hell do you have this i don't
know if people [ __ ] i never saw him
people could be bullshitting but i'm
like i'm not gonna put it past that
i saw more crazier stuff well it seems
like they would survive in the jungle
if they could get out there yeah i mean
they just eat plants
there's so much greenery in hawaii it
depends on what island right yeah
yeah what island did they see a gorilla
they were
yeah so i was like but it wasn't a wild
one was like a pet
oh a pet person somebody kissing with
pets i might be
maybe snitching and someone is crazy
well i think they're trying to limit
people's ability to own primates in
america
because uh you know i'm sure you heard
about that story about the lady in
connecticut
who uh kept a pet chimpanzee and then
attacked her friend and tore her face
off
no i did not yeah it's a crazy story
because
this lady kind of had a relationship
with this chimp
what kind of relationship yeah that's
what i'm talking about that's what i'm
talking about
yeah she was sleeping in the bed with
his chimp the chimp drank wine
and and and took xanax she's feeding the
chimp xanax
and uh the lady's friend came over and
the chimp
attacked the lady's friend is it a guy
no a woman friend
i think the lady was probably [ __ ]
blocking and the champ was like
[ __ ] all this and just tore her apart
i mean i shouldn't be laughing but
that's it's horrible that's why it's a
big
champ too and they're smart like what do
you what what don't you
chimps about like we come like they say
we evolution from those guys and they're
like
i know some like you see what the the
scientists are doing with these chimps
or
gorillas or whatever they do you know
and like like these guys are smart like
you can talk to them they talk back some
of them know
sign language it's like why are you
trying to mess with that
have you not seen planet of the apes i'm
sure they're like like three movies of
it like come on guys let's relax
they could it's like someone in the
future could do something like that like
take a chimp
and genetically engineer it to make it
almost as smart as a person or as smart
as a person
i i wouldn't be surprised if someone's
already doing it there it is
he's eating her shoot him scream the
chimps owner
yeah yeah he was a huge champ and he
he tore her face apart i think he bit
her fingers off did that woman survive
yeah yeah she was torn apart
yeah oh you don't show me the pictures
of the lady
yeah i have seen them they're awful
they're terrible yeah because chimps
chimps are different than other animals
that they know what you like they know
that you need your hands
and they know that you like your balls
they know that you need your feet
those are one of the things that they
attack they attack your face they tear
your face apart they pull your eyes out
they bite your fingers off they tear
your dick off and they tear your feet
off
yeah that's not laughing because i'm
just blown away it's [ __ ] up yeah
cause they're smart
they're super smart like like there's
[ __ ] movies on this
and there's people who's doing it you
know like fight there's gonna come a
time they're saying like you know like
modern warfare and stuff is like true
like
wi-fi and [ __ ] we're gonna have wars and
whatever and then the next thing is like
i hear robots and [ __ ] but what is it
to do is just you just [ __ ] start
breeding crazy
silverbacks and chimps and whatever and
then you make them
like i don't know you make a chip that
makes them somewhat human they can talk
and this and that and
you send them off to war put some kind
of helmet on them that has
some interface like some computer
interface with the chimps brain
and you have some helmet where they
could see things like you see like
infrared and night vision and [ __ ]
yeah yeah elon musk says his startup
neural link
ah [ __ ] they got us with this goddamn
you gotta shut that ad blocker off son
you gotta just give in to the
to the network elon musk says his
startup neurolink has wired up a monkey
to play video games using its mind
exactly see he's he's already ahead he's
already
you [ __ ] watch iron man yeah you
watch iron man iron man play both sides
too at one point you know
elon was in the [ __ ] iron man one of
them so i don't know
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience